ah
la comunidad indígena representa el 44
por ciento de la población colombiana y
tiene además una gran capacidad de
movilización política con líderes
destacados en las protestas que vive el
país la presencia del movimiento
indígena ha sido notoria el primero de
mayo más de 5000 indígenas de la minga
un grupo del sur occidente del país
llegaron a cali para apoyar las
protestas iniciadas con el paro nacional
del 28 de abril reivindicar sus derechos
y posicionarse en contra del racismo
además como acto simbólico los indígenas
han derribado estatuas de conquistadores
españoles en ciudades como bogotá o cal
y las comunidades ancestrales enfrentan
violencia en sus territorios derivada
del conflicto armado nacional en lo que
llevamos de año al menos 21 líderes
indígenas han sido asesinados y aunque
han intentado establecer un diálogo con
el gobierno para solucionar esta
situación en repetidas ocasiones no lo
han conseguido
[Música]
elegido a convención constituyente en
chile contará por primera vez con 17
escaños reservados de los 155 que
existen para los 10 pueblos originarios
que hay en el país 7 de estos escaños
pertenecen al pueblo mapuche el pueblo
mayoritario en el país del que se
autodeclaran formar parte un 10 por
ciento de la población chilena según el
último censo de 2017 además habrá dos
escaños para el pueblo aymara y un
escaño para los pueblos diaguita lincoln
and time o atacameño coya kritzia chang
o rapa nui caguas ar y el pueblo yagán
esto les permitirá avanzar en una agenda
común que seguramente incluirá el
reconocimiento de chile como un estado
plurinacional algo con lo que no todo el
mundo está de acuerdo y también un
avance en la autonomía funcional y sobre
todo territorial será la primera vez que
los pueblos originarios tengan voz no
solo en la institución sino también en
una constitución en chile
[Música]
en el ecuador una mujer indígena y rival
política del actual gobierno presidirá
al poder legislativo por primera vez en
su historia democrática un hecho que es
visto con buenos ojos por las 15
nacionalidades y 19 pueblos originarios
una señal simbólica del reconocimiento
de sus derechos políticos pero las
demandas indígenas por el respeto a sus
territorios la inclusión social
educativa se mantienen vigentes en las
mismas condiciones que los gobiernos
anteriores a pesar de crear alianzas con
un gobierno de derecha algunos sectores
del movimiento político pachakutik hoy
la segunda fuerza del parlamento
expresan sus reservas aseguran que no
existen acuerdos previos de
gobernabilidad ni pactos en detrimento
de sus derechos no renunciarán en su
agenda legislativa rechazara en las
concesiones mineras y petroleras la
dimensión de sus territorios las
privatizaciones o acuerdos de libre
comercio buscarán una reunión con el
presidente de donde fijarán las líneas
rojas aseguró el coordinador del
movimiento indígena marlon santi en una
asamblea sin mayorías pachakuti
requerirá de acuerdos de tres partidos
conjuntos para conseguirla mientras que
el gobierno asegura que gobernará en
respeto a las diferencias
[Música]